hay futuros si hay verdad es la primera
frase de los hallazgos y recomendaciones
del informe de la comisión de la verdad
en Colombia así habló su presidente
Francisco de rucs y nos tomaría 17 años
darle un minuto para honrar a cada una
de las víctimas
sin la presencia del presidente Iván
Duque pero con el presidente electo
Gustavo Petro esté prometió leer las
recomendaciones que salen de los
hallazgos la generación de 200 años de
soledad Si tienen una oportunidad
una segunda oportunidad
punta de rucs 9 comisionados el español
Carlos beristain ya ha participado en
otras comisiones antes rescate el buen
nombre de millones de personas y es una
buena noticia también para otros países
además de víctimas del conflicto también
estuvieron antiguos victimarios como
Rodrigo londoño ex comandante de las
Farc en la medida en que se recojan las
recomendaciones en la medida en que se
interiorice el horror que fue el
conflicto para que no se vuelva a
repetir la comisión de la verdad surgió
de los acuerdos de paz entre el estado y
las FARC de 2016 forma parte del sistema
integral para la paz juliet de Rivero
representa del alta comisionada de la
ONU para los derechos humanos en
Colombia habló para Franz 24 donde
Esperamos que sean las víctimas
realmente las que escriban la historia
de Colombia
y podamos rechazar la violencia entre
los hallazgos se encontró que el 80% de
las víctimas del conflicto han sido
civiles la comisión habló durante más de
tres años con más de 30.000 víctimas
pese a todo para el escritor y profesor
Fernando Ayala hay esperanza
un día de Renacimiento real de haberlo
hecho Si hubiesen un relato histórico
que trata de entender lo que pasó para
que el conflicto por fin termine